as the bettencourt family heads out to a
party on purge night you may notice a
sign in their front yard noting that the
house is armed by sand insecurity this
little detail is one of the many in the
purge series that references james
sandon from the original movie you may
recall that mr sandon used his own
company's security system to protect his
family and that didn't work out too well
for him he was purged before morning
despite the supposed poor quality of
these systems they aren't the only ones
to trust the sandon brand
state-of-the-art sand and security
who's providing the shell system sanded
oh the best even the nffa once trusted
sandon to install their system it's
surprising that sandon is still trusted
in the purge season one according to the
nffi website their main competitor gnd
security overtook them after james
satin's passing stating we're what
sandon promised to be and wasn't the
purge season 1 takes place in 2027 based
on the dates displayed on these security
systems we can assume henry's signature
on this release form was a typo that
sets the season
five years after mr sanden's system was
breached so i'm guessing improvements
were made to the company after his
passing to learn
all of the hidden connections in season
1 and season 2 of the purge tv series
stick around to the end of this video
i finally found a purge mask that not
only it block my speech volume but also
displays the goatee for the world to see
in all of its glory welcome to things
you missed if you can't get enough purge
lore from the movies there is another 13
hours of content to consider and it's
called
the purge again let's get into it
[Music]
the series opens with this shot of some
blue and yellow shower loofahs
yeah apparently these things are called
loofahs we later find out that these
colors represent the robe colors of an
organization called the mercy cult these
kids are manipulated into giving
themselves up to the purge once they're
old enough they graduate from these
yellow robes to the light blue ones that
they die in
light blue has always been associated
with the nffa and the purge but it's not
until season two that we discover the
meaning of yellow yellow is the color of
remembrance day the holiday that takes
place three months later to commemorate
the lives lost on purge nights
in the first episode miguel guerrero is
looking for a sister at this abandoned
structure this is actually an existing
location in new orleans but the blue
flowers and grim reaper happen to work
perfectly with the purge
as you know the dystopian government
party in the purge franchise is called
the new founding fathers of america and
the series features many locations and
references to america's original
founding fathers who helped america gain
its independence in 1776. the finale of
season 1
takes place at thomas payne high school
which comes up several times in the show
the stanton family lives on jefferson
streets named after thomas jefferson in
jane's flashback we see that she
attended thomas jefferson high school
there's also a street called franklin
we have and walnut and spruce
go across franklin the classroom scene
in episode nine shows the constitutional
amendments and many of the founding
fathers when miguel and pete search for
the school they come across a map called
washington streets named after george
washington
likewise in season 2 esme carmona
searches professor adam's house and
there's a framed picture of the lincoln
memorial
a location also seen in the purge
election year and in the last episode of
season 2 reports go out about illegal
use of weapons in washington square
another reference to george washington
if you've seen my previous things you've
missed episodes which you should have
you know all about the name
sabian every purge installment has a
character named sabian because they're
all written by james demonico whose
trademark is to use that name in his
writing
in the series sabian is mentioned in the
first episode forget
after you close the deal it's probably
gonna make a pitch for us to become nffa
party members oh i know i'm ready for it
i'll deflect my way out of that i
remember billy sage didn't close a huge
deal for a start-up here last year and
he didn't join
another element we come to expect in all
purge entries is the inclusion of civil
rights leaders in the sets as a
comparison between america's civil
rights movement and the mistreatment of
the poor in the world of the purge
this time you can spot it in the hideout
of henry's gang where you'll see images
of dr martin luther king jr
and other figures as well as a quote by
harriet tubman mlk and malcolm x are
quoted on the wall as well
another aspect we've become very
familiar with is the idea that each
purge is bigger than the last there are
two purges shown in each season
first there's the 2027 purge
prognosticators are predicting a
record turnout tonight we only see about
90 seconds of the 2028 purge so
participation is not mentioned but the
2036 purge continues the trend
estimates came in already 30 uptick from
last year in every district
biggest purge in city history the 2037
purge is no exception
you ever seen crowds this big never this
year is tracking to become the largest
purge we've seen
one of the big season one plot lines has
to do with jenna being pregnant
there are a couple of signs early on
like her asking for tylenol and ordering
salt water instead of alcohol
that being said i still find this to be
kind of a risky question
how far along isn't that obvious the
second episode would be filled with more
connections to the movies as well as
easter eggs connecting it to other
horror movie franchises
[Music]
in miguel's quest to find his sister he
comes across a triage van a concept we
saw more of furthered on the timeline in
the purge election year there are a few
election year references in the series
like when miguel figures out that his
sister is at the carnival of flesh it
goes there and here's this phrase
chanted by the announcer
that's the same motto chanted by edward
owens the main antagonist of election
year in season two there's a cold open
set and company meeting for the
merrymakers mass company and we see
their logo strongly resembles the style
of masks used by the russian tourists in
election year we also see that purge
tourism trend in another cold open in
season 2. later on in season 2 there's
also a part where the van gets flipped
over i don't know if it's a reference
but we've definitely seen it all before
in
election year one of the trials that
miguel has to overcome to get to
penelope is an obstacle known as the
gauntlet
if the name sounds familiar you may be
thinking of the 2016 halloween horror
nights maze the purging gauntlet of fear
which happened two years before the
gauntlet appeared in the show other than
the fact that there's actual danger in
this gauntlet it really does feel a lot
like a halloween horror night's maze
i would definitely be the camera guy
wearing skull makeup and this is
actually the stunt coordinator of the
show making a cameo there are actually a
lot of funny purge groups this season
my favorite of which is these guys who
dress up as golfers for some reason and
when they take the victim away i love
how he just does this gideon motion
imagine being that guy the purge is
produced by blumhouse who has always
been known to put funny stuff into some
of their horror movies one example of
this is happy death day which is
referenced in the entrance area to
pete's cantina masks are checked at the
door and on the rack you can spot the
baby mask worn by the antagonist and
happy death day the property is
referenced again in season 2 where
college students ben and turner live in
a frat house that seems to be the same
location as the sorority house from the
happy death day movies i believe the
campus they attend is the same as well
it looks like ben's dorm room even has a
poster for a similar mascot in happy
death day it was the bayfield babies
this poster is for a team called new
orleans babycakes there are plenty of
other references on the wall of masks
throughout the night though like the
sheet mask and fox mask from the 2011
movie you're next a mask that was worn
by one of the mercy cult purgers in
episode 1 the mask of godhead from the
purge anarchy more on that later the
mask shown on the sign appears to be the
same mask worn by the polite stranger in
the original purge movie and that mask
actually appears on the rack in episode
8.
it's not just the movies that are
referenced though this may be the
finders keepers app mentioned on the
nffa website
of course i can't leave out the first
purge i mean i could it's my channel but
i'm not going to one of the storylines
follows a businesswoman named jane who
looks out her window and sees the only
building lit up on purge night is a bank
this is part of the idea that the purge
is fueled by money
jane works at an equity firm and in a
flashback to her job interview she says
the following
i've been following your firm since i
read a profile in forbes back when i was
in undergrad
this is the second time that forbes has
come up in this franchise the first
being on a police officer's name badge
in the first purge
side note in jane's flashback we see her
boss checking her out as she leaves but
she never sees him so how does she have
that in her memory
it doesn't make sense there's another
flashback in the following episode where
miguel and penelope's parents are
offered money to stay home on the purge
we can see the pamphlet that says statin
island
experiment this is the same pamphlet we
saw being handed out in the first purge
the first purge isn't the only movie to
have this struggle of classes
many of the entries make it obvious that
the nffa is in power because they are
rich and the purge is all about making
money there's actually a piece of
graffiti in new orleans that says too
much thrill which is a slang term for a
rich person so this
is likely a form of propaganda against
the nffa we see how their brainwashing
of the american people has affected
people when jane's employee allison
purges her co-worker in order to ensure
her promotion i'm not sure i understand
the logic here i mean sure
murder is legal on this night but
wouldn't she still be fired for offering
a co-worker
anyway penelope is taken away by a group
of purgers wearing nun outfits i'm not
sure if this is a thematic choice given
how some groups are starting to see
purging as a religious act thanks to
nffa propaganda or just the results of
the show coming out in 2018 and creepy
nuns being really popular at the time
what's equally unclear is if the
anti-nffa checkpoints set up in the
street are related to the anti-nffa
group from anarchy all i can confirm is
that a couple of their members seem to
be wearing berets as some of the anarchy
resistance did this headline seen at the
end of season 1 is also familiar if
you've seen anarchy it warns of heavy
consequences for purge night
revolutionaries
oh and here's another funny part
this is part of the aforementioned
carnival of flash which is also where
you'll probably find the most hilarious
mask in all of purge but the carnival
may have more sinister affiliations than
you might have realized the o in the
logo is a celtic cross turned 45 degrees
this is a symbol used by neo-nazis and
ku klux klan members it's also displayed
in the merch card inside the letter o
in shopping the carnival also sells
merchandise with kkk depictions
these racist groups have been known to
work with the nffa and take advantage of
the purge in the movies penelope spends
like three to four episodes captive at
the carnival thanks to her vengeful
ex-boyfriend henry
meanwhile rick and jenna escape after
the purge party that they're attending
is attacked by revolutionaries
then they get held at gunpoint at home
by their neighbor ross this part
actually drives me crazy it's as if they
don't understand that there can be
conflict in the story without someone
holding someone at gunpoint
especially since we just saw like three
to four episodes of that kind of tension
and then if you're gonna do it again
almost immediately at least make it make
sense like she's about to shoot this
dude and the people standing behind him
aren't even gonna move what if she
misses what if she doesn't but she blows
his brains into the crowd or the bullet
could go right through him
now before i move on to season 2 there
are a couple of things present in the
background
all throughout season 1 that i've yet to
touch on
what if i put the plus head mask on over
the angry abraham lincoln mask
that's kind of not bad the new founding
fathers of america have one practice
that the originals never would have been
able to
using technology for surveillance of the
citizens i forgot that you were the
eavesdropping type david
you know i'm always watching and
listening we saw this more than ever in
the previous entry the first purge where
i pointed out the eyes that symbolized
the always watching government the tv
series gives us
way more of that in the baton court's
house you'll see large artwork in the
hallway of a human eye when they return
home safely after the party i noticed
another eye up above a painting near the
front door
in henry's apartments during the
flashback he's also got artwork of an
eye a very illuminati looking one at
that
an interesting note here is that it says
the word purity which may go along with
the often repeated phrase purge and
purify
i can purge and purify myself another
note on this piece is that the eye
actually has a sword going into it a
possible foreshadowing of what happens
to henry his cornea is permanently
damaged in a fight with miguel
jane's purge knight is a crazy one with
many destinations one of which is a
sexist human art gallery held by her
boss david riker he too is the proud
owner of some artwork of a big
human eye at the end of season one
everyone is brought together by the main
antagonist joe owens joe has been saving
each of the main characters because he
wants to put each of them on trial where
they can either give a worthy confession
or be purged by joe himself
joe is very much like jigsaw
specifically from the 2017 self-titled
movie
both characters go around capturing
people who have wronged them in order to
try to force them to confess to their
wrongdoing
also eleanor is here so there's that joe
plans his victim's abductions by posting
all the information he has onto a big
wall
something we've seen in the saw
franchise in the past we learn he's
extremely smart and good at math in a
flashback and he even builds traps that
try to account for every possible
outcome
they even share the similarity of having
basic non-suspicious american names
oh my god joe
john
anyway the reason i bring up joe owens
with the eye motif is because he too
ends up getting an i poked out
when it comes to joe though i'm not
entirely sure that he's dead in the
final battle miguel shoots his
bulletproof vest
shoots his knee and then kicks him into
the pool we never get confirmation that
joe died and i'll circle back to that
later in this video
the last thing i have to hit on before
fast forwarding the season 2 is our crew
reference easter eggs if you're new to
this channel filmmakers love to hide
their own names in movies and apparently
tv because we're very egotistical it
starts at the rehab center penelope
discharge from
kantra rehabilitation center is named
after producer alyssa cantrell there's a
list of visitors at that rehab center
that includes first assistant director
paul udo
and production assistant jeff reynolds
the character rick bettencourt is named
after co-executive producer and writer
mick bettencourt pete's cantina has a
poster for a jazz show by neil aurelion
which happens to be similar to the name
of the art director nelio really on
david reicher shows off an art piece
that he calls an original la mercier
this is probably a reference to
executive producer sebastian k
la mercier during one of joe's trials in
episode 9 he tries to get a confession
from someone who picked on him in high
school and shows a yearbook
page most of the other student names on
this page are all crew you can pause if
you want to read them all
finally there's a flashback to the
moment where rick and joe had their
falling outs the words mcnight house are
written on the whiteboard in the
background and that's a nod to
cinematographer kevin mcknight
the motif of an eye as a symbol for
government surveillance would continue
in season two and there would be a lot
more examples almost as many as the
amount of times a character expresses
their dislike for this damn
night i'm gonna try to sleep through
this god forsaken holiday i hate this
night it must be the night
it's nice to officially meet you on this
night
i hate this night this night grabs
everyone this is their way of protesting
this damn night man let's go find a
place to wait out the rest of this
night i just hate this night god this
night
this night is she knows what night it is
this night has been a long one i think
this night has taken a toll on all of us
maybe he's having a bad night but this
night it's relentless
i hate this night this night just kind
of makes me start thinking about what's
really important
oh baby will probably make this night
even harder
she hated this holiday she wouldn't be
outside i'm done with this night
god i hate this holiday i hate
personally
the first eye motif can be found on the
necklace of ben gardner's girlfriend
kellen there are many instances of eyes
being present in the graffiti found
around the city whether it's on a random
piece of plywood
on the bank on a warehouse accompanied
by the text i'm watching you
or in an alley the presence of these
eyes play an even more important
role this season where the plot
literally revolves around the nffa
surveillance team and the areas with no
cameras known as dead zones are very
important for the main characters
the surveillance team is known as the
nffa's visual analytics department but
most people have a different name for
them
you're government yes i am which
department
visual analytics nice in the sky their
office has computers with an animated
desktop background the logo says new
founding fathers of america established
1984.
of course they weren't really
established in 1984 they were
established in 2014. which you know if
you've seen my horror history episode on
them
later episodes do not contain this tax
the 1984 is a reference to the novel in
1984 and by george orwell which is about
a dystopian future government who
controls the population through constant
surveillance much like the nfa who
always has eyes on their citizens
in the second episode of season two ben
relieves his urge to purge with the
purge video game in a kiosk
in the mall he exits when another guy
complains about how long he'd spent in
there and sees that he's wearing a shirt
with three pairs of gorillas eyes
esme's sister has a poster of a peacock
feather in her room which kind of looks
like an eye although maybe she's just a
jimmy
world fan esme has a pillow in her own
home with a giant eye on it
the opening of episode 8 also shows off
a mask with one eye perhaps a callback
to henry from season one in the frat
house there's a beer pong rules board
which also
for some reason contains a pair of eyes
the main antagonist of season two is ben
who loses his mind after nearly getting
purged by a man in a godhead mask many
of you wondered in my anarchy video if
this is the same god head from anarchy
that guy was black and this guy's white
so i'm gonna say
no they're not the same guy but i guess
creating this mask
became somewhat of a purge tradition as
you'll recall we also saw one in season
one
maybe the nffa emblem posted next to his
bed is a clue that he's going to become
evil i'm not sure why the big brain meme
is here though maybe it has something to
do with ben
being an example of the findings of
professor adam's study that aggression
on purge increases aggression throughout
the rest of the year
so those brain scans they show that
violent acts can light up the pleasure
centers of the brain like a drug
especially those in the younger
generation those who grew up with the
28th amendment
ben listens to an audio program from
bobby sheridan the same speaker who
inspired joe owens in season one at one
point he listens to the same recording
that joe had on in the season one finale
people will always surprise you when
they don't want to die
but when you embrace the purge
when you commit to the healing power of
its violence
anything can happen ben starts taking
out victims off purge the first of which
is a farmer who is eventually found but
the cause of death is reported as heat
stroke i was having a little bit of
trouble
understanding why the nffa would lie
about this it could be part of their
plan to give people the impression that
the purge is working that the crime
during the other 364 days a year is down
but then why be so strict about the
people whose crimes went past 7am
maybe they only want to admit crimes
occur when they think they can catch the
person in order to make it look like
nearly all criminals are caught
and since ben took out the farmer in the
countryside there were no cameras on it
this could also explain why they let him
off the hook after he admits to smoking
marijuana
if the public doesn't know that a crime
occurred it's in the nfa's best interest
to keep it that way what i don't
understand is why that doesn't make him
a bigger suspect towards being the
campus killer
the whole campus killer thing is
honestly a pretty big plot hole ben is
playing video games with his friend
asian andy they're using an xbox one
i'll excuse the use of a console that's
22 years old in universe and just assume
that they're fans of retro games
what i can't excuse is the fact that
this is where asian andy is taken out
ben lies about having been there that
means there are no cameras in the
hallways of the dorms even though we
clearly see that there are cameras on
campus in the first episode
this is awful i feel bad even taking a
picture
demonetized speaking of that first
episode i think there may be a big
callback to
the first movie a man named marcus finds
himself stranded outside during the
purge and tries to get his neighbors to
let him in but nobody does it seems very
similar
to the situation that dante bishop was
in in the first film that's not the only
time that marcus seems to be connected
to the purge movie that started at all
because his flashback scene takes us
back 14 years to 2022
the same date that the sandins had their
home invaded by the purgers
this is also where we meet plus head
kind of a minor role to justify
selling masks but i'll take it plus head
can be seen rolling with his buddy
run mouth marcus has one more connection
to the first movie though he has dinner
with his wife michelle and what they
believe could possibly be their last
meal because it's right before the next
purge she's playing debussy's claire
dulune in the background
so if this is our last meal
this was the same song we heard at the
very beginning of the original which
accompanied the montage of perjures from
previous years marcus and michelle both
have the same dinner idea in mind that
night
you did not cook the night before purge
we had sushi on our first date remember
yeah where do you think i stopped before
i came home that one feels a little too
close to the anniversary shared by nick
and amy and gone girl
it's we had that joke that our sex was
too good
ordinary so these are 2 000
we're so cute marcus realizes that
someone is trying to purge him because
of the bounty posted on the dark web the
site is called ivory road a parody of
the silk road which is one of the first
dark web drug trading sites
wait so how do you know about this i
know about that as a fan of the internet
and internet history not as a customer
another important detail in the scene is
the calendar app seen on this phone
which is one of only a couple details
that help confirm when the season takes
place we know it's before 2037 because
ryan's driver's license that expires in
late 2036 is still valid
but it has to be after 2032 based on how
far back the flashbacks go
that gives us a range of four possible
years where it could take place and this
calendar only aligns with one of those
it's 2036.
just don't take any of the dates of
birth here too seriously
this guy doesn't look 55 but maybe
people age more gracefully in the future
and apparently the headphone jack is
going to make a comeback and
a tape recorder seriously i feel like
the technology problem in the purge is
never going to get fixed but this ivory
road account becomes something that
marcus would keep coming back to in
order to try to catch whoever ordered
his heads he puts up a post of his own
to try to find someone to get him more
information one of the responses is spam
advertising cheap boner pills the nffa
doesn't want you to have
the final storyline follows a band of
thieves and the nffa agent whose
computer screen is home to even more
things you missed the purge isn't nights
where all
crime is legal but for whatever reason
the first four movies and the first tv
season focus almost entirely on murder
no other crime is addressed outside of
just a tiny side character here and
there
season two totally changes that making
it one of my favorite installments we
see bank robbery conspiracy
treason and hacking that makes it all
the more disappointing that season 2 is
the only entry not to have a blu-ray
release
that makes it kind of difficult to find
little details but with that all being
said
here's what i found during the initial
bank robbery scene tommy has a shirt
that says break the rules
he breaks his gang's code by going back
for one more bag of money as the sirens
are beginning to sound
this is what leads to him getting
arrested because he doesn't make it out
in time i mean he should have tried to
make the argument that his foot was
lifted
off the ground i mean how does this work
anyway is it college rules or nfl
we need some clarity james demonico
anyway tommy goes to jail for one year
before his execution date on the next
purge
during his time in the clink ryan brings
him a book it's the 1844 novel the count
of monte crista about an innocent man
who is wrongly but deliberately
imprisoned
the book ends with one final message all
human wisdom is contained in these two
words
weight and hope this was ryan's way of
telling him that if he holds on until
purge night they may have a way of
breaking him out
in the meantime they also plan their
heist for the next purge
our city attracts a lot of people on
purge night although it hasn't been
updated in a couple years now this
actually calls back to the nffa website
that was used to promote each purge
movie in 2014 for the purge anarchy
iteration of the site they did a blog
post about the top five purge
destinations where new orleans ranked
number three in the country i guess that
held up for over a decade it's actually
referenced again in the fifth episode
where miami and new orleans are hot
tourism destinations during the purge
part of ryan's plan for stealing the
bank's money is to let the jackals steal
the money for them and then steal it
back later in the night the jackals are
thieves that steal from other thieves so
ryan's plan involves giving them a taste
of their own medicine when he and esme
look up the jackals identities i noticed
some familiar names like trent surreal
and [ __ ] these are also the names of
professor adams test subjects from her
experiments about the effect of purging
on the human brain
the photos are different though and the
test subjects did not survive
so i think this is a mistake like they
accidentally used the same name twice
for minor characters
season two is not void of crew reference
easter ends ryan has a flashback to his
days in the police force where we see
the locker next to his is labeled
federica
named after the second unit director of
photography federico verratti during
that same flashback ryan catches a
surprise out in the field on purge night
what the [ __ ] are you doing out here i
already brought up jeff reynolds he was
a crew reference easter egg in season
one ryan's director of training at the
police academy was amy kresbach who was
named after the truck costumer there's
also an article written about one of
ryan's heroic actions as an officer
it's written by james crafton that's the
production secretary and there are
mentions of names like paul emily and
raul uda
probably all family members of paul udo
the first ad who was mentioned in season
one the other article shown here
mentions a gas station incident where
ryan is named again along with the
superior andrea ziv
her character is named after writer and
co-producer crystal hewtonzitt
the article mentions a couple more crew
members travel coordinator cali martin
and second assistant director ben ladau
esme then moves on to a letter that ryan
received from the mayor in 2010
it's signed by a colleen e moody who is
also the script supervisor
there's one other crew reference later
on remember the part where asian andy
raves about dr updale's book i'm halfway
through dr updale's foundations of the
experiment
unauthorized kind of a history buff
in a ffa history yeah it was a
bestseller didn't she kill herself after
creating the first purge night no
that's been debunked she died persian
not only does that explain exactly what
the nffa told the public after the
events of the first purge but we see
this book throughout the series
first on a poster then parker finds the
book itself in ben's possession where we
see the author
m martin a reference to the prop master
michael s martin there's also a poster
that can be spotted in town advertising
for purge of the musical a story of good
vs evil
i wonder if that's a sign of things to
come that's right you heard it here
first the forever purge is going to be
a musical why aren't you in school
he got cancelled well that one hit home
a little bit hard
not the first time the purge has
predicted a disaster either when i did
the things you missed episode on the
first purge i pointed out this wall art
of a boxer and explained how it
represents the character nia in the frat
house where ben tortures his fellow
fraternity members there's a portrait of
a football player in a very similar
style another callback can be seen when
ryan's gang busts tommy out of captivity
it seems that the mercy cults bus from
season 1 has been repurposed and is now
used as a prison or transport vehicle on
purge night season 2 comes to a close as
ben truly becomes the new godhead during
the 2037 purge
he takes out most of his frats but
parker survives as ben is hunting him
down he's hit by a car and wakes up in a
triage center
when he comes to the first thing he sees
is a jesus statue looking down on him
perhaps this angers him because he now
sees himself as a god
he doesn't want to be looked down on by
this religious figure
you're trying to play god
but you're not god
marcus is able to sedate him and save
the rest of the triage center but ben
survives
in the final shots he can be seen
preparing for another purge it's an
interesting choice and if my theory is
correct that means both major villains
from the tv series the new godhead
and joe owens both survive as of now the
purge tv series is cancelled and the
upcoming movie the forever purge is
supposed to be the ending of the series
how cool would it be to see joe
and ben two of the most powerful purge
villains we've seen so far
team up as secondary antagonists in the
franchise finale
whatever happens i'll be sure to cover
the forever purge here on things you met
so make sure you don't miss it by
subscribing to cz's world for new
horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive if you don't
want to get purged stay home but if you
have to go out
wear a mask
you